[Applause]
welcome back we're here on the Internet
and I wanted to get to this issue during
the show and we didn't but luckily
probably more people actually see us on
the Internet
so let's talk about what you're involved
you're doing a play out here yeah
reading yes we're doing a reading of a
play called eight and it's based on the
court transcripts from the federal court
challenge that we launched against
proposition 8 here topic
prop 8 here in Cali treating anti gay
marriage right that was against gay
marriage we we formed the American
Foundation for equal rights we hired
David Boies and Ted Olson the two guys
that opposed each other
on Bush v Gore right and we tried the
case in the district court in San
Francisco we won and it's now yes it's
now and it's now on appeal in the Ninth
Circuit and Lance black Dustin Lance
Black who wrote milk won an Academy
Award took the the trial transcripts and
made a play out of it we did a reading
of it in New York on Broadway with
Morgan Freeman and a lot of great actors
it went over so well that we're gonna do
it here during Loney's doing yes George
Clooney here in Los Angeles okay is
George Clooney gay I have to ask him
look at he's got Stacy Keibler how gay
could he be George Clooney is gonna play
David Boies and I'm gonna direct and I
play also a part in as well all right um
and and what did you think about rick
santorum cuz i he's obviously the most
anti-gay candidate he would say I would
guess Pro Bible or whatever he would say
anti-gay but I feel like this is an
issue where America has really moved
they have the gay community is the one
group in America that is not considered
equal under the law and so and well
actually atheists I would argue are in
there we're not equal well so now you
certainly don't get any representation
for a group that is about seventeen
percent now I mean always growing the
people who say none when you write a
religious affiliation none 17 present
bigger than any other minority no
representation in Congress nobody dares
know that that there are tens of
millions your and there I mean you're
you're right about that that we don't
have that representation I include
myself in that same seventeen percent
but we can have representation we I mean
and gays can have representation well
but under the law under the law atheists
have the same legal rights if there's
any other there the last group you can
really just [ __ ] on publicly and
everybody applauds it you know George
Bush not everybody I mean this and and
Rob is right this is really these civil
rights at the issue of our generation
and I'll tell you what that it warm my
heart I was driving my kids to practice
yesterday and writing what baseball and
volleyball and they asked me Mom you
know why are all the Republican
candidates so against gay people and I
said well you know I that that's a
really good question because they think
that because they're different that that
they don't they shouldn't be treated the
same as everyone else and my
twelve-year-old son that said that's
really stupid mom you know and that's a
rate you know we would argue my um
problem I'm the oldest one here at this
table and when Barack Obama ran for
president old I'm gonna supported him
and I was you know but campaign I did
all the things but I in the back of my
mind I said kind of blah you know I was
one of those people said can a black
person all dead be President and my
children said the same thing what are
you talking about why is that a big deal
right and you're exactly right we've
moved past that
the young people uh uh you know in the
generation within the next generation
they don't have a problem with with gay
marriage they don't have a problem when
Rick Santorum said well what about if
you allow that then I guess a person
could marry three people or a dog and
this is the contract it was against and
they and they booed him because they
don't want to marry their dog this is
the contrast that we
not all of them not all of them I feel a
lot of you guys wanna marry this is the
contrast we have between the entire
Republican field and present I thought
President Obama was all says he's
against gay marriage when his position
is exactly the same as that of Mitt
Romney isn't hey you know how he is when
he said the right of Z Cheney he is
evolved he's evolving on that issue and
I will be D prized if in this next
election cycle then he doesn't endorse
do you believe that he was ever sincere
and honest I do not I don't think I
don't think he's sincere about a lot of
things but the reason why he's not
sincere I can totally understand he's
the first black president he can't come
out for weed okay we're gay marriage he
has to be super tough on national
defense I mean appalling crime when Mitt
Romney sometimes allows people to think
he believes things that maybe he doesn't
really think and and a completely venial
act when President Obama does the same
thing all right so mom I'm not the one
who says it is I'm the one I just told
you that let's let's move on your
Democrat President Obama is the
president that has done more to advance
gay rights than any president in
American history the repeal of Don't Ask
Don't Tell making sure that LGBT
Americans have the opportunity for a
hospital the novel DOMA but wait exactly
let's not pat him on the back too much
the repeal of Don't Ask Don't Tell was
polling at 75% approval even a majority
of conservatives were for repealing
Don't Ask Don't Tell
so the fact that there are Democrats
found it in the book but also 1,900 yes
not to defend the Defense of Marriage
that's a big win that that's a big leave
me this is a president who has been bold
and clear about the importance of
equality or LGBT Americans in this
country okay but he is still to the
right of Cheney and Laura Bush on game
at you have a thorough again shows this
season you could spend the first half
attacking the Republicans and then we
can spend the next the general election
I'm just trying to keep it real and keep
it fair and I think he will I think in
the second term when he's got nothing to
lose you're gonna see the real Obama
come out including his admission that
he's an atheist - okay
I keep getting confused right that's
what they would say ah is there more of
a push Black Knight asks to get minority
and female candidates to run or just
those who are most likely to win ooh
let's do you we are actively engaged in
recruiting any qualified candidate who
is interested in running and willing to
work hard and support standing up for
the middle class and working families
focusing our tax policy on making sure
that everyone in America has an
opportunity to be successful not just a
wealthy as most fortunate Americans
which is today I think if you look at
the Democratic Party and the
representation that we see in Congress
it is a reflection of our American
families chamber during the State of the
Union look at the side of the chamber
that the Democrats sit on and the side
of the chamber that the Republicans sit
on and you can notice a dramatic
difference in who chooses to affiliate
as Democrats and who chooses to
affiliate as Republicans the diversity
in the Democratic Party is remarkable we
truly are the big time this goes back to
something I was saying the televised
portion of the show about the weakness
of party structures I mean if you were
to walk through the halls of the
Republican National Committee and say
who here thinks that the kind of the
party should do a lot to get more female
minority candidates you'd have an
overwhelming consensus but candidates
choose themselves that is the way it
works in the United States and that is
it doesn't have that's not the way it
always was it's not the way it has to be
it's the way it is now and that that
means oftentimes parties are at risk of
being captured by vocal minority groups
and Democrats had this problem a lot in
the 1970s when the party got swung much
farther to the left than its leaders
wanted to be Republicans have that
problem now stronger party structures
would go a long way especially in the
Republican side you know the British
conservatives have outright quotas for
the number of women on their party list
and that is and I'm not going to I'm not
going to say that advisers do that
that's maybe as far as you want to go
quite that far but it has had a powerful
effect but gee changes everybody's own
party where the United States ranks as
percentage of women in government in the
world ninetieth yeah very very low 90th
but there is a reason that the
Democratic Party is
far more diverse than the Republican
Party because the natural home
politically on major issues to Hispanics
to women to Jews to asian-americans a
the the the diverse spectrum awfully big
apply to african-americans the entire
spectrum of diversity is comfortable in
the Democratic Party because we stand up
for the issues that matter to those
communities and Republicans shun them
okay I'm gonna get Herman Cain back I
gotta go thank you very much
you're a terrific audience they are
terrific Real Time with Bill Maher ask
Bill and his guest to a question right
after the show at HBO calm